Claudia major ist jetzt unser Gast sie
ist Verteidigungs und
Sicherheitsexpertin bei der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik schönen guten
Morgen guten Morgen in einem Monat jetzt
sich der Kriegsbeginn zum zweiten Mal
jetzt dieser Absturz die russische Seite
beschuldigte die Ukraine das Flugzeug
abgeschossen zu haben was spricht dafür
was dagegen ich glaub wir müssen uns in
dem Fall sehr klar vor Augen führen was
wir wissen und was wir nicht wissen das
kam ja eben auch schon raus es gibt zwei
Sachen die wir wissen das Flugzeug ist
abgeschossen worden und der gefangen ist
war gefangen aus geplant der nicht
stattgefunden hat das sind die einzigen
nach meinem Wissenstand verlässlichen
Informationen und alles andere die
Listen über die Gefangenen austausche
und so ist bislang Spekulation und
deswegen ist auch die Forderung vom
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski meines
Achtens richtig die Verbündeten zu
bitten was habt ihr eine Information
kann man das überhaupt klar machen und
es verweist auch noch mal darauf dass
dieser Krieg auch im Informationsraum
stattfindet dass Russland ganz klar
versucht mit
Desinformationen versucht diesen Krieg
zu framen zu beschreiben und auch in
seinem Sinne mitzuführen und deswegen
finde ich immer man soll sehr vorsichtig
sein mit den Spekulationen es gibt nur
meineschtens zwei klare Fakten wie
gesagt abgeschossen und der Gefangenen
aususch hat nicht stattgefunden und wenn
man jetzt die ukrainische Seite
betrachtet der hur der ukrainische
Geheimdienst sagt nicht viel außer dass
ja die Maschine ist abgestürzt und man
wiss aber nicht wer an Bord gewesen
welche Folgen könnte denn dieser Absturz
jetzt
haben es geht in der spekul der Liebe
was mir nicht so was ich nicht so mag
aber ähm es könnte natürlich noch weiter
die Beziehung aber die Beziehung
belasten sind sowieso kaputt ne aber ähm
ich sehe vor allen Dingen denusagen
propagandaeffekt dahinter ähm und es ist
für mich noch mal ein Beispiel mehr ähm
wie Russland auch mit den ukrainischen
Kriegsgefangenen umgeht wir hatten im
Sommer 22 schon mal einen Fall
wo ukrainische Kriegsgefangene in
Russland durch den Raketenangriff
gestorben sind ähm und das wäre dann
wenn es dazu wirklich sich bestätigen
sollte dass zweite Beispiel aber noch
mal ich würde das wirklich sehr
zurückhalten und sagen wir wissen gerade
nicht viel die große Frage für mich ist
ändert was an der Front oder nicht und
es ändert daran nichts und die Lage an
der Front ist sehr verhärtet eine ja
zermürbender Kampf ist das da viele
fordern die ganze Zeit Taurus Lieferung
von Deutschland da gibt es jetzt
Neuigkeiten eine Art Ringtausch das
berichtet das Handelsblatt also Berlin
liefert nach London diese Taurus
marschlugkörper London wiederum dann an
die Ukraine ich weiß leider den Typ
nicht wie er heißt irgendwas mit Shadow
genau
was könnte das bewirken und wie
realistisch ist das das wäre eine Option
für die Bundesregierung aus dieser
endlosen taurusdebatte auszubrechen und
sie endlich mal zu beenden für die
Ukraine wäre es eine gute Nachricht weil
sie noch mehr von diesen stormshadow von
den weiterreichenden Munition erhalten
würde
m Taurus ist weiterreichend hat noch
spezifisch Fähigkeiten also Taurus wäre
schon noch mal ein qualitativer
Unterschied gewesen aber angesichts der
dramatischen Lage in der Ukraine ist das
schon schon mal sehr gut wenn Sie mehr
stormshadow kriegen Frankreich hatte
kürzlich angekündigt 40 mehr von seinen
skalyp zu schicken die in die gleiche
Kategorie gehen es bleibt aber eine
Frage für die Bundeswehr ungelöst wenn
die Bundeswehr die Taurus abgibt ist da
eine Lücke das heißt man müsste sehr
schnell die Nachbestellung beauftragen
und sehr schnell dafür sorgen dass wenn
man sie an die groß an an Großbritannien
liefert dass dann die Lücke in den
deutschen Beständen sehr schnell
geschlossen wird also die Lage an der
Front ist ja auch deswegen
wahrscheinlich so schwierig für die
Ukraine weil Waffenlieferung bzw
Munition noch nicht erfolgt ist bzw noch
nicht in ausreichender Menge wird da
jetzt in Zukunft etwas geschehen was die
Situation was offensiven angeht ändern
könnte außer jetzt ab also die Taurus
bzw Shadow Lieferung ja ich glaube die
Grundsatzfrage um die es gerade geht ist
geht Russlands Strategie der Zermürbung
auf Russland spielt darauf dass sie bis
zu den US-Wahlen die Ukraine und den
Westen weiter zermirben können die USA
kriegen Hilfspaket nicht durch den
Kongress sie sind in Gaza und im Roten
Meer beschäftigt in Europa gibt es den
Streit über die nächsten Hilfsgelder und
das ist eigentlich die die Frage gelingt
es den westlichen Staaten langfristig
die Ukraine zu unterstützen oder nicht
so wie es militärisch momentan aussieht
wird die Ukraine nicht in der Lage sein
bis Herbst eine größere Offensive wieder
auf dem Weg zu bringen sondern es geht
in diesem Jahr für die Ukraine wirklich
durchzuhalten wenn es geht die Linien zu
halten wenn sie sich zurückziehen müssen
Russland so viel Verluste wie möglich
zuzuführen aber es wird W die Ukraine
ein extrem hartes Jahr werden und damit
auch eine enorm große Herausforderung
diese Unterstützung am Laufen zu halten
vielen Dank dass Sie heute morgen bei
uns waren Claudia major war das danke
sehr gerne